first off I want to say I'm very honored
to be here because I heard stories of
how there were individuals who either
had something at 8:00 p.m.
and decided to like stay on just to be
able to catch it there are other
individuals who drove like 53 minutes
from another town just to make it here
so on my hand yeah it feels like
pressures on but on the other hand it
also feels great because like i I've
been a coastal person for most of my
life and so like I've lived on the two
coasts of North America Canada and
United States I lived in Singapore for a
long time and I rarely come to a
landlocked area a part of a part of town
part of the country and so no I'm used
to like this coastal buzz of like all
the latest ideas which I know is like
there are less barriers now but it today
for me it's very eye-opening just to see
that the community out here and how
vibrant it is so for me it's an honor
and I think I have to also say Shaun's a
great guy but according to some things
that he says don't listen to Shaun's a
great guy and I'm glad that I'm able to
be here okay so today when I was
thinking about brainstorming a little
bit over what might be a value to
deliver to the PI data community here I
was thinking mostly along the lines of
what's a valuable practice that we might
want to encourage but is under-under not
done very often and so the practice that
I decided to talk a little bit about is
testing it's a very simple easy to get
started topic but we don't talk about
about we don't talk about it very often
and at least amongst peers who are in
other firms who work at other places we
don't I don't see I don't hear much from
them about the practice of writing tests
as a data scientist okay so I'm gonna
flash the slides up for the next ten
seconds if you would like to get a copy
of the slides you actually can just scan
the QR code with your iPhone
camera and you'll get it otherwise if
you can read the miniscule text at the
bottom it's testing for data scientists
at the bottom alright and you will have
I think the CI system has finished
building the slides and so it's up there
ready for the latest version that I'm
presenting should be up there as well
I don't mind questions during the talk
but I will adhere to the rules set down
so please keep the questions short but
feel free to interrupt me any time in
between and also if you end up like
browsing through your phone during the
talk I'm just going to assume you're
looking at the slides on your phone okay
cool so just a little bit about myself
and where I work before I move on I work
for the Novartis institutes for
biomedical research as Rose mentioned
it's a lot of machine learning it's a
lot of machine learning work I also
happen to just do on one project happen
to play every single role possible so
software engineer data engineer CI
system quality QA testing everything it
it revealed for me why I know I it
revealed for me a lot of deficiencies in
knowledge let's just put it that way I
know some stuff about software I know
some stuff about testing but really the
core expertise that I know that I'm
competent in is taking a problem
defining it taking the problem to
completion and then delivering the
prototype and then maybe working with
others no no no offense against I
actually really love the fact you guys
want full ownership of the whole step
because a lot of projects get lost on
the throw over to software engineering
or throw over to to production it's just
I also know my limitations and and
that's something I need to I need to
learn and thankfully being dropped into
the deep end gives you that learning
opportunity I got into the back to MIT
through the back door and walked out
through the front if you are ever
curious about how that worked out I can
talk about it I'll just take it like
walking out through the front door is a
good one and finally I like Python it's
the primary it's the first programming
language that I really delved deeply
into and found that it was
friendly to use community was friendly
packages ecosystem very rich lets me do
a lot of stuff in few lines of code so
and and a lot of people give back as
well so I think it's a it's a great
community I also have a lot of friends
who use are my manager uses our we have
a good relationship leave it there okay
so first off I have a question to pose
to you how many of you would identify
identify as a data scientist of some
kind statisticians included I don't want
to exclude you all because I believe
your works fundamentally very similar so
then how many of you write code more
than 50 of those who've raised their
hand
how many write code in a programming
language more than 50% of time okay
and how many of you write tests for code
of those who had their right hands
raised okay so not a lot not a lot and
so this actually does confirm that my
talk today has a purpose and I'm not
just speaking to the preaching to the
choir okay so for those who choose not
to write tests what are the reasons and
I want to be completely non-judgmental
here and I really mean it um what are
your reasons for not writing tests could
we have a few volunteers first and then
second time okay big one a second not
sure how to get started yep okay got it
the coat is not the deliverable okay
cool cool stuff and then right behind
you one time code exactly good back
there okay yeah so sometimes it's a lack
of knowledge and that that same same
thing for me
yep
they're getting to answer
is correct there's no reason to test
and we as data people can fall into the
same trap yeah yeah absolutely now that
that was very frank and I again don't
want to be judgmental I have fallen into
that trap to myself so yes cool there's
like there's a there's there's just that
try that other neural network and like
forget about that test it's like not not
so important like that's interesting and
then of course now if that was one time
code
I'm not bitten in the butt later but if
that was not one time code that I needed
to write a test for well good luck to me
and for those who do write tests can I
ask what are your reasons
mm-hmm okay so you've come to depend on
it and you need to know that you you
also can plausibly forecast that you'll
need to modify it yeah okay cool and I
saw a few hands there and then we'll go
to the right hand side after Bradley yes
developer and user of their own tools
yeah okay okay and I saw another hand to
the left it's a requirement so that
someone above said you have to do it so
you do it
gotcha they're right there you want to
save time could you elaborate right
might move slower mm-hmm
gotcha that's right I totally agree and
back there at last point intellectual
property rights can that that is
actually the first time I've heard this
reason can you elaborate on that
like for instance there there is an
algorithm out there that understands
what every customer what they want
tested
okay okay okay
we'll make two exceptions I saw two more
hands yeah absolutely and yes yes
absolutely
you need to well it also relates to
having confidence about what what you're
doing and that you can have confidence
that your program or your code handles
edge cases correctly yes absolutely
okay so apart from IP all the other
reasons are valid reasons that I've
heard before and what I hope happens is
that in the discussion afterwards those
of you who haven't written code for
maybe not the best reasons do find
others who who who write sorry those who
don't write tests for maybe not the best
reasons find those who do and also at
the same time those who you who know the
ecosystem for testing in Python I'm
gonna allude to it later but give a talk
at PI data and Arbor look for Shawn and
he will sign you up to be a speaker all
right is that correct absolutely correct
okay great
cool so today I want to I want to convey
a few points namely if you are
self-identified sales data scientist who
is part of the broader data science
community and a big portion of your role
is in delivering something that involves
code to another team then investing in
writing tests today will bring you all
of the benefits that we discussed about
just now namely you'll save time later
on you'll decrease team frustration and
you'll increase team productivity and
when I say testing I really don't mean
this only in the sense of only testing I
actually mean this has a broader point
with respect to other software
engineering skills now I'm not expecting
every data scientists in every single
project becomes you know writes the most
seasoned software engineered code no
what I'm trying to convey is if we apply
some basic software engineering ideas
like writing modular functions that have
limited scope like writing tests and
also writing Docs how many of you write
Docs not very many I am guilty of that
myself
I don't really write I don't really
write Docs on some occasions but if we
do adopt these practices we reap all of
these same three benefits and so today
I'm just going to focus on testing okay
so to convey the message I'm actually
going to tell you two projects tell
about two projects that I worked on one
is a hobby project the other is a
project at work alright and the first
one is how the use of automated testing
tools in Python allowed me to reveal
weak spots in my code so before I could
even think of the weak spots automated
testing tools revealed them for me
and so then that gave me a lot of
confidence in you know building what I
wanted to build the second one is
actually how writing tests for my code
as well as for data automated sorry
greatly accelerated a lot of data
analysis workflow downstream because we
had great confidence in what we had to
borrow the thing that Kyle works on
great expectations I had perfect
expectations about what I was in what I
was what data I was using okay and so
this is a I want to use these two
stories to convey those points so let's
start with my hobby project it's a
project in which I had been hacking on
since grad school and in this project
the goal is given protein sequence
predict drug resistance value so your
data sort of just looks like that now I
was interested in this problem in grad
school mostly because I was interested
in this phenotype genotype phenotype
problem given a genotype of a via
is predict a relevant clinically
relevant phenotype for those of you who
want to try to improve upon this I I
don't want to discourage you from trying
but do know that you probably won't make
any money out of it because there are
commercial systems for this so this is
really a good project to get into
machine learning and if you're in the
Biosciences machine learning in the
Biosciences or life sciences this is a
great project to attempt but don't have
any expectations that you'll make money
so we get data that looks something like
this I got protein sequence and I want
to predict the number it's as simple as
that
there's nothing really complicated ok so
you can imagine it's a protein sequence
and machine learning algorithms don't
really take in strings so you have to do
some feature ization of the sequence you
have to convert that long string into a
vector and do it for every single sample
that you have so you know we might write
three functions and I'm just I'm just
going to give you the rough architecture
by the code it's really I got a file I
read in the protein sequence from the
file
I then feature eyes the sequence and
return the features and then I take
those features and load it into a pass
them into a secular model and then I get
back a column vector of numbers we okay
with that so far so good okay so this is
sort of your very run-of-the-mill
standard kind of supervised machine
learning project question to the crowd
now what have we assumed here in this
function that you think might plausibly
you need to be tested give it a moment
actually talk with your neighbors
another neighbor that you didn't
socialize with over this for about a
minute or so think about it and talk
about
okie Dokes alright let's gather back I
wanted to ask if anybody had ideas about
things that we're assuming for the first
function the one that I'm highlighting
up here what might we have assumed in
this function okay that you can find the
file cool there the correct format okay
anything else oh yeah okay cool
very good so there are a lot of
assumptions that you can see are
happening in this first function and
those are all valid what about the
second function what part of me okay
right anything else
ah okay very good is the is the what do
you call that the alphabet correct
anything else okay
okay anything else we're assuming
oh it's numbers my my bad sorry I should
I should have numeric yep okay all right
we're gonna move on how about that final
one
what have we assumed here okay yep
anything else yep yeah okay anything
else valid point yes okay yep that's
right so especially when we're going
into a production system that's
something we want to think about right
there yes that as well okay and final
one back there
yes okay cool very good
so as I'm discovering slowly everybody
here does have the instinct we all do
actually do have these instincts so my
my hypothesis which I'm going to throw
out is that most of us don't write tests
because we are lacking time I think
that's the primary reason and the other
is that we we know we don't depend on it
but then the primary one is primary
drivers for work we don't we don't have
time but anyways let's come back to what
we want to test so in this particular
example I'm gonna focus mostly on the
last two functions right and it's partly
because of time partly because it's the
easiest to cut sort of grok all right
so part of me sorry to grass okay so
first off let's write a test for future
eyes now for those of you who are not
familiar with the testing machinery in
the Python world there's a package
called PI test and it lets you write
functions that are decorative of your
tests so in order to test the function
feature eyes you would import the
function feature eyes from wherever your
library is then you would write a
function that calls that is called test
underscore some informative name and
inside there you place all of your tests
effectively what PI test is doing is
eliminating away a lot of the
boilerplate code that you might
alternatively write if you were to use
the built-in unit test framework now if
you're in this scenario where you can't
install packages use the unit test
framework if you're in a scenario where
you can I would strongly recommend that
you use the PI test framework for
testing because it provides a lot a lot
of conveniences and it also has a rich
ecosystem of extensions that I'm not
going to talk about today but I want to
keep you keeps your keep your appetites
wedded okay so how would we write it we
might say let's input something that is
a known valid example so let's take a
known HIV protein protease sequence
stick it inside here pass
through feats and then assert some
properties of that of that of the output
okay and so that's something that we
might choose to do we can also do a test
for the function predict okay
in this case I've only chosen to do a
simple execution test or you know just
run the code kind of a test the this is
if you are in a hurry this is this
example pay example based execution test
is by far the simplest example that you
simplest test that you can write you
actually if you are testing in
interactively in a Jupiter notebook you
are doing execution tests all the time
does that make sense so if you do that
just copy the pace copy and paste that
block of code into a test and execute it
unless of course it takes a long time to
run but if if nothing else this is the
bare minimum so I sort of hinted are we
done with this function then with his
tests clearly not okay so as some of you
mentioned the input to the machine
learning model is an array or a matrix
that is of width five times the length
of the protein sequence okay so focusing
on just this one particular problem if I
passed in a sequence that was less than
the the sequence length that the model
was trained on I'm gonna get something
that's less than five times the length
of that HIV protease in the case of HIV
protease which is what this one's for
it's always 495 long vectors so I pass
in something because it's 99 amino acids
long if I pass in something that's 98
I'm gonna get an invalid input but I
pass in something that's a hundred I'm
still going to get an invalid input so
in order for the model to work I need to
ensure that my input to the model is
nineteen is 495 is a 495 long vector
I also therefore need to make sure that
the input to the feature i's function is
a 99 long string at the minimum and I
deliberately phrase it that way
because in the feature i's function you
can also have invalid inputs there are
as someone mentioned at the back invalid
amino acid letters O is not a letter in
the amino acid alphabet and so if I were
to pass in a string that has letter O it
should crash the program right so first
off if the user inputs a string for this
project if a user inputs a string that's
not 99 letters long the program should
crash and if a user inputs a string with
invalid characters something that's not
drawn from the 26 sorry 22 defined
letters for the amino acid alphabet or
24 I can't remember it's one of the two
there there are ambiguous characters
that are allowed and there's a special
asterisk character that is also allowed
if you're not amongst the set of
characters the program should also crash
right so let's try first by making the
code a little bit more robust okay so
first off we can say we can we can
declare a test that looks something like
this first off I first declare what the
acceptable letters here in this case I'm
deliberately omitting the asterisk
because I don't expect it to be present
we then take even though it is one of
the valid characters I'm not expecting
I'm designing the program not to not to
just ignore it we have the feature eyes
function and we can do a few checks
because we know this feature eyes
function is something that the machine
learning model depends on we therefore
bacon some checks hard checks over here
the length of the sequence must be 99
long and the set of characters that are
present inside the sequence must be a
subset of the acceptable characters and
then and only then do we do stuff to
future eyes okay
so then once we have this we can
actually make the test more robust as
well and so how would we do this this is
where I'm going to
reduce a few concepts simultaneously so
firstly you can use PI test to check
that a program errors out correctly
right you can use PI test to check that
a program errors out correctly and the
way that you do that is to use this with
PI test raises syntax which allows you
to say as which allows you to declare I
expect that feature izing this sequence
if the sequence is not 90 line long to
raise a value error which I had
previously declined declared in the
function the second thing that I'm going
to introduce here is that you can
actually use a generator an automatic
generator of test examples that comes
from the library hypothesis and how many
of you have heard of hypothesis before
it's a very very good library for
generating all sorts of test data that
you might want to pass into your test
functions okay you can generate the
string you can generate all the Python
primitives so strings lists of stuff
tuples of stuffs dictionaries of stuff
nested data structures that's all
possible guess what I also found out you
can generate numpy arrays you can also
generate pandas data frames which is
amazing right if you think about it I
can declare what data are supposed to
look like in my data frame and make sure
that the functions that operate on data
frames operate exactly as I want so I
can say use using pipe using hypothesis
and it's compatible sorry and it's
decorators that are compatible with PI
test I can declare that this function
should be given as part of the sequence
argument text that is drawn from the
acceptable letters alphabet and I'll
just for convenience hard code stuff
that are you know within the correct
bounds or most expected bounds okay and
with this simple syntax that I can start
to declare how I want what kind of data
I want passed in into this function to
test it okay so you'll notice I
deliberately get there
I ignored the invalid character example
for the time being but you would use the
exact same thing except in this case
replace the alphabet with something that
comes from in the full suite of
characters yes you can generate all of
these examples very very quickly in an
automatic fashion it is generating
random inputs but oh sorry so I think I
misunderstood the question
your question is if I had two arguments
and two things that I wanted to pass in
right then would would we have would
they be considered independent and
therefore generated combinatorially or
or is it yes it is the latter yep so you
don't you don't necessarily have to
cover the full parameter space okay yes
it is part of the Python decorators
syntax so the given function modifies
this function into some other magic
stuff but then you know it reads well so
you're saying this function should be
given a certain set of stuff John I
think this is this is a little bit out
of my realm of current knowledge but I
think it is possible to make them
deterministic one thing that hypothesis
does is it intentionally shrinks your
examples to find examples that break
your code minimal examples that break
your code okay and I'm sort of letting
the conclusion out of the bag everything
that I'm going to talk through over here
is the ideal way to discover to write
your tests in reality I use hypothesis
to brute-force my way to finding all the
edge cases that I never would have
thought of because I'm too lazy to think
of them right and so hypothesis will
find them and it makes me much more
clearer about the code that I write
okay so we're now with that one function
better tested we're in a little bit of a
better position right that function now
has become something reliable question
yes no problem
yes hypothesis has a default I think of
a few hundred examples that it will
generate so it's it's doing a lot of
stuff for you and in some respects you
can think about the old way of testing
where we have an example based execution
- well example based test is being like
automatic manual testing I have to
declare certain types of certain
examples right that's automatic manual
testing so in if you watch the tutorials
at PyCon on one of them being escape
auto manual testing with hypothesis by
Zack had field
I forgot his surname but he's from
Australia he's got a conjugated surname
and so I can't remember at this moment
but Zack is the guy who one of the
people who maintains the hypothesis
library and he has a full-on tutorial
about that so I would strongly recommend
that you check it out okay
I think it's I think it's for future me
to be able to read it more than anything
else and I'm I mostly write code
defensively against future M neva that's
that's how I write my code so it's got
to be easy to read okay so we're in a
little bit of a better position the
function as it stands defends against
unexpected inputs so we have some
defensive programming happening the
tests will help us catch breaking
changes and if you hand this over to
your engineers who are going to do take
things into production or if you hand
this to your future self six months
while you're taking it into production
then you're going to thank yourself or
your engineers are going to thank you
for writing robust code okay so I know
it is not not every team will have the
opportunity to take the thing to
production not every project will end up
like that but if you do it if you do it
for the projects that you know are going
to go to production then you've written
robust code for production purposes if
you try to do it to the best of your
ability on projects that are not in
production you have gained practice and
experience writing better and better and
better tests okay so that's that's my
word of encouragement for this little
bit here so like I mentioned just now I
actually use hypothesis two instead
brute-force my way to all of the invalid
inputs found all the invalid inputs made
the code more robust and then continued
continued iteratively so you can use
hypothesis both as a library for just
brute-force testing but also for
figuring out where the mote you where
your most obvious bugs might occur okay
so it's a it's a great library writing
tests in short also helps you catch
catch bugs cool now the other story that
I want to talk about comes from my work
work which is the development of a
protein engineering platform at work
we're doing enzyme evolution I am part
of the three person
a computation informatics team that is
supporting this platform development and
so in this protein engineering platform
we're writing lots of code but it's a
relatively simple code base there's lots
of like independent utilities that we
have to write with some function sharing
and because I already did talk about
testing functions I'm actually not going
to talk about that in this example I'm
gonna focus on data I'm gonna talk about
like writing tests for your data and I
think it's important okay
so our data because we are in the
development phase of the platform and
we're developing assays the assays will
change from enzyme to enzyme where we're
therefore faced with this complex
evolving data sort of requirements right
I can set up a database for one enzyme
I'm probably going to have to ditch that
database if we have a new enzyme to load
data unless I structure things correctly
so basically as the platform gets built
out there's a lot of things that are
evolving sometimes as scientists will
say oh yeah this is the way we want to
calculate it and then three weeks later
we realize ah that really wasn't the way
we should like calculate the activity of
the enzyme we need to use a different we
need to use a different math equation so
the output that we're interested in
changes underneath us okay so that's how
these data requirements change and we we
do try to normalize the database as far
as possible to the best that our tiny
little data scientist brains can
understand what database admins do but
yeah it's it's complex and we found
ourselves in this place where to get to
the place where we wanted like just the
data that we wanted like human readable
easily possible we have to do all these
crazy joins okay it was not fun how many
of you have maintained 30 lines sequel
joins to create your database views yeah
and when things change you have to run
back up the chain like if something
really way upstream changes you have to
propagate them slowly down to
so the final view here was not fun so
what we ended up deciding was we're
gonna ditch all of our views because
we're not gonna do this
we made some intentional choices because
we're not going to do this database
management thing long term I t's going
to help us for the development phase
we'll just like cache the raw data and
like use pandas to do our joins and
define all of our joins in pandas code
rather than worry about sequel joins and
maintaining things and wrestling for
hours each time to update update the
joints right okay so that's what we
ended up doing so yeah if you update and
maintain a 30 line sequel view you end
up with this face pretty often so
instead caching pandas dataframes was
the right thing to do sorry I have like
these puns I really like okay so the
problem here the problem here is that if
you think if you work with Python
packages you know how important the API
is there's a reason why I have a slight
distaste for the tensor packages that
have been developed because they don't
respect the numpy api which is extremely
idiomatic likewise I've had friends
colleagues ex colleagues who in their
other jobs encountered data analysts who
willy-nilly changed the schema names
going from capital letter to the
lowercase and the likes and I said Andy
you gotta write tests for your data man
and that's when this really started
showing up in as like a real consequence
that someone might have to deal with
because all all of Andy's production
systems were broken by a capitalization
change so yeah your schema is the API to
the data now we can have debates about
whether you want to access the schema
directly or you want to have like API
access data access layers or not that's
a choice you make but then whatever it
is your schema is the data API it has
got to be stable or if changes that
happen they have to be caught as early
as possible before anything in
production fails okay so
so yeah if the schema changes even
slightly we want to know this ASAP so
how do you then write tests for data I'm
gonna give you one example this is not
by by means by no means ever the most
authoritative example but if you really
need to get up really quickly without
using highly engineered frameworks or
libraries to do it and you just need to
have something quick and dirty here's
how you can do it so you might want to
test some things you want to check that
your column names are correct sometimes
you might want to also check that your
row indices follow some order you want
to check your column data types you want
to check that what you expect to not
have any null values are actually not no
yeah you want to check that the bounds
of your data are are correct you don't
want to have if something is supposed to
range from zero to 200 and you get a -
999 who was that data analyst - yes
okay can you think of any more beyond
what these examples that I've listed
yep okay so you want to make sure that
your distributions if your predictions
depend on a particular distribution of
data that distribution of data should
remain the same okay anything else okay
you want to make sure that there are no
duplicates where there are not supposed
to be any duplicates okay anything else
are the syntax of your queries now that
assumes we use sequel but yes yes
absolutely yes
when you do what do you call that in
sequel and you call those like foreign
key referencing right yeah you want to
make sure that that's all correct as
well anything else if not I think we
pretty much covered it so an example of
a very lightweight example of how you
can get tests written for your data is
to do something like this you you query
your data and you explicitly write your
tests that way okay that's one way of
getting up to speed now Kyle here works
on great expectations and I actually
deleted the slide but I still wanted to
mention it like the only thing that has
stopped me from using great expectations
at work is time which is exactly the
same reasons why same reason why some of
us don't write test time and that's the
that if you look through how great
expectations work it's a little bit
complex in getting set up but there are
easy entry points into it you can you
can use that to to declare some of these
tests in much more readable declaration
has these test functions that go assert
or expect that this column is not null
or something like that okay it's got
this very nice syntax that between plain
English Lang in plain English function
names tells you what you're expecting
about your data which is I think where
the name of the package comes from right
great expectations
some novels
there we go so yes so it is another
package to check out okay now I wanted
to talk a little bit then about how
tests accelerated our workflow okay we
use data caching so we cache like once a
week we pull down the latest data onto
our local machine because we know we're
not going to maintain that database long
term but we still need to use it to
prove it it's okay we cache the data we
write some tests for the data if you
remember like I had mentioned earlier
there were times where we were changing
the sequel views because of instability
in our upstream data we ended up
spending hours on this right but when we
when we got the views correct sorry when
we got the views correct instead in
pandas code we could just look at the
output data and say this I know is
correct and we start writing code
against it we actually built on top of
that so we have all these custom queries
that come in sometimes if I didn't have
the right view in place I could spend
hours writing another view in sequel to
try to get it right whereas instead in
pandas code which is merely a language
that I just understand better than
sequel in pandas code I had that
function in a matter of mere minutes
right so think about saving hours of a
day going to get the data that you
actually need because you had great
confidence and great expectations
perfect expectations about the data that
you were handling okay now of course the
way to have absolutely perfect
expectations is to never have the schema
change under you all right so fight back
against the data analyst
who changes the capitalization of your
column names okay so we we took like a
ten-minute time me and my intern in
Basel we pair coded remotely I wrote the
function in a notebook sharing screen
and we're and and at the end of it it
was actually not me who realized that we
might have taken ours it was him
because he he had been wrestling with
views for a long time and he
at one point said wow we might have
taken the whole afternoon to just get
this correct and here we are with the
chart in 10 minutes so go figure
tests were great Knicks really
accelerated the workflow okay so I'm
gonna wrap up with a few points on how
to build out the regular practice of
testing especially if you're in a data
science team that doesn't have existing
an existing culture for it the first one
is borrowed from Novartis --is latest
millennial craze of being hashtag
unbossed okay go ask our go watch some
videos on YouTube about like our CEO
talking about unbossed and you know
culture and all of that but I really
believe in this one because I do that
with my boss a lot when being on boss
really just means take the initiative so
if you don't want to if you don't want
to so so if you if you don't want the
the pushback and you don't want to have
to ask permission but ask ask for
forgiveness that's really what it's all
about
okay so go out and build stuff that make
it easy for yourself as well as for
others to write you know these tests go
push your DevOps team every since every
every company's gonna have a slightly
different DevOps set up DevOps are
extremely crucial to getting the culture
of testing going when I mean DevOps
really all I'm talking about is the
continuous integration systems that
automatically test your project code
base on every single commit you want
that in place you don't want like humans
hitting make tests in from your make
file right you want a system that just
does it so you don't even have to think
about it so go build the CI systems
knock on the door of your dev ops team
tell them you need help setting it up if
you don't know how to do it they'll
guide you through it right tests you
know learn how to do the manual testing
first and then automate all of that away
all right which brings me on to that
next next thing you automate everything
you don't don't do auto manual testing
with your examples automate the
generation of examples don't do jupiter
notebook based testing
you just sort of visually inspect the
output declare think carefully if you
want to build the culture of testing you
need to make things really convenient so
set up the CI system don't allow adopt
workflows that also prevent code from
being merged untested especially if this
is not your fun project at work but
something that someone is going to
depend on okay finally building
credibility is important because I know
there is going to be the human factor I
was talking with Sean this afternoon
about like what how hard is it to change
things right in the culture of change
humans are like the biggest barrier it's
not tech it's it's humans so you need to
build a credibility with others that say
changing up a little bit the way that we
do our science is going to have much
greater benefits even if they are
invisible at the moment they are going
to have dividends paid off way down the
road with engineering teams being happy
to work with data science teams if
that's the set up at your firm with your
future self being able to accelerate
your work later on because you invested
in a lot of automation and testing so
build a credibility if you notice a
benefit right to your DevOps team a blog
post an internal blog post or an email
or whatever
DevOps teams have a hard job and they
get bashed quite often at least a
neighbor if they some some system fails
so they're always happy to hear of
success stories and if it comes left
comes from left field in a team that
isn't expected to use DevOps tooling but
is now that that adds to the joy of
their work and finally deliver talks
about testing okay cool so some
conclusions you depend on data or code
write tests for it it these these three
lines sort of remind me of some Beyonce
song so it will pass on that okay some
resources that are available on the
slide if you want to get started and
finally have
happy testing thank you very much you
mentioned testing benefits yep but in a
lot of research contests at the very
front what you're doing is essentially
prototyping gap ninth out of your ten
implementations you might end up
throwing away yep so do you
nine out of ten knowing right only two
out of ten do I test and it's purely for
the practice of getting familiar with a
tooling and not over investing so I
totally agree with like the time
investment is not something you want to
waste right so the usual the at least
for myself the the usual decision point
for writing a function and therefore a
test is I've copied and pasted that funk
that block of code more than once right
and so then once I know oh crap I'm
going to depend on this block of code
that's when I actually go and write a
test just for that little piece of code
the full pipeline where I'm prototyping
like I actually don't write tests for
the full analysis pipeline until I know
an engineer is going to use it
yes I says so the question is am i a
good person if my coat is not 100%
tested yes you have intrinsic value as a
human being on a more serious note even
the packages that I've built that our
open source are not 100% testers it's
really hard to do testing at a
confidence level of a hundred percent
statisticians please pardon the pun so
it is much easier of course to be able
to say well okay I'll test to the extent
that I can and as soon as I catch a bug
we'll write a test that makes we'll
modify the function and write a test
that explicitly brings out that bug and
makes sure that we don't ever encounter
that bug anymore
so that has happened at least three or
four times in the protein engineering
project that I'm working working on
anything else where the assumptions
might not be clear from just go
that you're testing 100% of what the
model okay so the question here is code
is easy to measure in terms of coverage
even though example coverage may not be
a hundred percent lines of code coverage
can be a hundred percent how do we do
that for data and for that I'm going to
ask for help from Kyle I'm wondering if
you have any ideas on this because I
haven't thought deeply about this okay
okay so how would you measure data
coverage yeah okay no problem I'm sure
it's a great discussion question
afterwards okay okay
okie Dokes do you have a preview of like
what but what ideas have at least been
thrown out okay no worries alright
thanks a lot though thanks for the help
I had a question up front and then back
there and then there yes oh my gosh yes
and so if the view itself is complicated
we do try to modularize what we're doing
and declare in our comments of the
docstring of the function that creates
like the intermediate views we declare
where we intend this function like the
output of this function to be used and
we actually I have found myself
explicitly naming this output is
expected to be used in that next
function so and it just provides the
text contextual link between those
functions now yes yes it is absolutely
that I don't know how to do this but
I've never been able to successfully
comment and document my sequel views
when they live all on the server and not
in my codebase right and that makes it a
lot more difficult to maintain okay I
had another question behind
okay so frameworks for testing model
outputs model outputs look like data so
if your model output function is wrapped
in such a way that you return to pandas
dataframe you can use great expectations
for this for this purpose if you don't
you can use I guess PI test machinery to
at least do some first pass testing in
place so yeah I'm probably you're
probably thinking about oh the model
does it predict an unreasonably high
number for example given some certain
data or some impossibly low number that
sort of thing right yeah so that that's
what I would approach how to approach it
yes
next I came to the tests aha ah okay so
actually I'm ah okay okay here yes so
yes um checking data well okay so with
so the comment was that we can use
hypothesis style tests to test our data
I'm not a hundred percent sure how how
to do it on the spot but it sounds
plausible to me it yeah it sounds
plausible but I'm not sure how to how to
how how I would like live code it in
this moment
I with that I've certainly learned a lot
I'm certainly also guilty of being lazy
we all have our moments but I appreciate
that
Eric took the time to share some of his
thoughts on testing especially the data
science space yeah and so with that lets
thank you again for a great talk thanks
a lot
Thanks